this is a production of Cornell
University so Thank You Margaret for
that wonderful introduction but one
moment I kind of almost cried because I
was like oh gosh I am going so uh kind
of switching gears I guess because like
you mentioned we kind of have that so so
obviously the topics up there at the
moment but um so so basically the Green
Revolution the Green Revolution
increased yields in the crops that we
eat and it selected down to very few
crops globally and one of the the costs
of taking that focus on a few crops and
focusing on yield in particular I mean
there was actually a reduction in the
concentration of the mineral elements
that we have in many of the foods that
we eat and a reduction in diversity so
with that as well there's an increasing
interest in the nutrition of the food
that we eat as well so understanding
interactions between genetic and
environmental factors is paramount to
understanding nutritional quality of the
food that we eat what do I do
okay so there are various organizations
that provide information such as the
USDA and the World Health Organization
that will provide information on the
types and die types and diversity of
foods that we should in order to attain
the essential and beneficial elements
that we require in our diet so 22
mineral elements and so these these if
we have any reduction in these this
diversity of food we're expected to have
a reduction in the amount of mineral
elements that we have in our diet as
well which would affect our health so
you may be familiar with this and this
is from the USDA giving an idea of the
types and the quantities of food that we
should eat in order to get these mineral
elements
but as we're aware all around us we
don't have to look too far to see that
there are some people that is this too
late maybe a little too late there may
be some people that actually don't get
the types of diet they require in order
to get these minerals in their diet so
let's look at Baltimore and in Baltimore
there's a map here and we can see that
the red here represents food deserts and
at food desert is defined by a lack of
one of these one or more of these three
layers here so the first one here is a
physical access to healthy food
affordable healthy food and desire and
knowledge to eat healthily so if we were
to have any one of those lacking in the
in in the area geographical location
that we live in we would have expect we
may expect that there would be the
possibility we'd have a reduction in the
healthy food that we can access and the
diversity of mineral elements that we
may have in our diet as well and
therefore affecting our health as well
so but that also happens on a global
scale as well so here we have a map of
the world and this is the incidence of
global zinc iron vitamin A and iodine
deficiency in the world and just looking
at that very quick brief look at that it
shows you that there are many countries
around the world with you know from mild
to alarmingly high incidence of
deficiency of these various elements but
more than that
considering just these elements here
maybe one or more of these elements
about two billion people globally are
expected to be deficient in one or more
of these elements
so it's a really a really important
question here so but it's easy to
resolve so here you know just
supplementation is one of the easy ways
that we could actually just remove one
remove this problem for people so
supplementation directly with tablets is
iron for example or supplementation to
the plant in fertilizer form we could
have foliar feeds and that type of thing
or another way may be fortification or
processed foods but we actually argue
that biofortification so that's using
the innate genetics of the plant is a
sustainable and long term method
approach to actually providing the right
nutrients to people that actually don't
have access to the food in the right way
that they should do actual delivery of
nutrients is is potential especially to
those people the marginalized poor
that's when we consider people in
sub-saharan Africa for example for
places that around the world that
actually don't have as much access to
the mineral elements that they might
require for a healthy diet
so the question man is this if we're
going to do that what is it that we need
to know in order to address this this
question so from research in plants we
become aware that we were aware that
genetics regulates the elements that go
into the plants that we work with in the
crops that we work with but we also
aware that one of the other factors of
that is the soil type the soil PH
fertilization and these other factors as
well so genetics here we've denoted as
uppercase G and an environment is
denoted is uppercase e sound familiar
guys I think so yeah but then there's
another element to this as well it's the
interaction of the both G by E okay so
before people start throwing things okay
so I want to briefly talk about some of
the genetics
I'm glad I'm gonna just talk about iron
now so the path of iron through the
plant so I'll do it from this so first
we look in the rhizosphere and here we
can see insoluble iron within the
rhizosphere
which is being chelated and then passed
through channels and I've highlighted
this one channel here yellow stripe one
because we're going to talk about that a
little bit later so from the yellow
stripe one we're gonna take this path
that takes through the cellular and
intracellular pathways going past the
Kasparian strip and then towards the
xylem and the phloem in the xylem it
will be taken up through the plant and
into places such as the leaves and then
in the leaves because we're dealing with
iron now which can be we need it as an
essential element but it's also toxic in
high levels what we can do is what it
does is that something like the N ramp
here will actually take that iron that's
in too high quantities and actually put
that and store it in the vacuoles and
keep it safe from the other functions in
the plant
and then continuing this passage up to
the parts of the plant that we eat then
we find that the iron will be in those
areas there so there's this whole
process that really we know parts of it
I mean I've just explained it to you
right we know parts of this process but
there's also a lot that we don't know so
that's what we want to talk about today
what don't we know so what is so maybe
let's talk a little bit about the iron
ore so the mineral nutrient and trace
element composition of an organism so
that's the definition of what an I
enemies but it comes from it's like an
intermediate intermediate of two other
terms as well so the first one sorry
where this it seems there was an
incompatibility with computers but so
the MIT metal ohms say that correctly
that's the in got or inorganic metals
within the plants which is smaller than
the Ino and then we have the organic
Loma like weight molecules and inorganic
metals and that's the metabolomic maybe
we're more familiar with so then the
iron ohm then is the nutritionally
relevant minerals and trace elements so
now that we know that so how can we
influence the mechanisms to improve
nutritional quality how is it we can
really get in there and understand the
genetics in order to make it work for
what we want so the problem is is
currently known genes do not explain the
whole story of elemental homeostasis so
our solution on that our take is we want
to know the complete set how is it we
get to know more of what's going on the
complete set to give a bigger part of
the story and so our method is using
Association mapping on 2320 elements
that and these twenty I remember there
was 22 elements to for the that we were
looking at essential elements earlier so
we're looking at 20 of those though on
10 diverse environments and for
different populations so that's the
complete thing that we're looking at
there
but I'm going to talk to you about just
three of these populations and you may
be looking at this going what on earth
is that so I'm going to just walk you
through it
so these squares represent on the
triangle
they represent the genetic diversity
that we find in each of these
populations so this one over here is
probably quite familiar to most of you
is the nested association mapping panel
and the comments that I have in the
middle are kind of relative to the other
populations so here we have the NAM is
expected to have greater power than
maybe the second Bayes diversity panel
sorry and then great resolution and less
diversity the Mays diversity panel the
second one here is expected to have less
power statistical power and greater
resolution and greater diversity now you
might be wondering why this square is in
the middle here and that's because some
of the recombinant inbred lines that we
find in the NAM are actually also found
in the diversity panel as well and
coming to the third population over here
the heterogeneous inbred families we
have the square again and that tells us
that these hips are actually created
from the NEM and these hips that we
create nearly isogenic Plains which is a
slightly different question than we were
asking for the first two populations so
I'm going to talk
very briefly about the NAM I'll be quick
don't honestly twenty-five NAMM founders
so of reasonable diversity genetic
diversity these 25 founder lanes were
all crossed with b73 they were selves to
the f6 generation and then we have 25
recombinant inbred families and within
each family we have 200 common inbred
lines a total of 5,000 individuals and
those are would also be found in the
diversity panel as well so okay so we're
getting into some of the data now so
working in the Nam so in the Nam
we planted at four different locations
quite diverse locations and then in
these locations we're looking at
elemental accumulation by location so
here I've picked two random elements for
you
one is manganese and one is molybdenum
now the concentrations at each location
is seen in the box plots
and then below that on the x-axis such
as you can see the locations there but
below that again we have the pH the soil
pH for each of those locations and just
to try and make life a little bit easier
for you I've colored those by the amount
of accumulation of the availability of
that element that we would accept expect
with a pH of that value so for example
in North Carolina we have a pH of 4.5 we
would expect for manganese to have a low
availability
likewise in North Carolina for
molybdenum we would expect to have low a
poor availability again once there but
what do we see the data that we actually
see is that the concentrations for each
of these within the kernel that we're
taking here is actually we expect to
have poor availability but we don't have
the lowest for the kernel concentration
and likewise for the manganese we don't
have the lowest again so that tells us
that you know the concentrations in the
kernel are not tracking directly with pH
that we see in the locations that we're
looking at so that tells us once again
there's something else at play here so
while I get to the point here the point
is if we believe it's the genetics
that's at the greater proportion of this
list spelling out the story for you so
when we look at the heritability broad
sense heritability which is the genetic
contribution to the phenotype that we're
observing when we look at these two at
the bottom here manganese and molybdenum
we can see that their heritability is at
0.6 which is a reasonably high
heritability but then let's look over to
these other ones here and we find that
we have some others here 0.3 or lower
heritability which just tells us that
actually there's probably a greater
influence of the environment on that
phenotype as well so let's take that
point home there so we're talking about
the G and the E and the G by E together
so the next slide so okay great
right okay what's going on here okay so
now what I want you to do is I want to
just take you on a little journey
through the process of preparing the
data for Association analysis and so I'm
just going to sort of talk briefly about
these but get used to these slides
because these slides will be coming up
again and so I don't have to talk
through them again I'm just going to
give you the same type of thing so here
we have the icp-ms so what that stands
for is inductively coupled plasma mass
spectrometry and what that is is it will
actually record the concentration of the
the element that we're looking at and
give us some raw data and tell us how
much of that is actually in the plant
and then for that we sampled for the
NAMM roughly 50,000 seeds then here we
remove out laid out layers using the
median absolute deviation 2.5 standard
deviations from the medium and then here
we do it box-cox transformation and then
here we do the best linear unbiased
predictors and that's basically to
correct for errors in the data that we
get for each lane and we did those for
element 4 Elaine ok so then we moved on
from here and we looked at joint linkage
which is considered to be a more
conservative method of doing this
analysis and then below that we did
Association mapping genome-wide
Association study and then for
resolution within the genome we did 28
approximately 29 million
snips so here I put QTL like rain
because literally that's what it's going
to be like we get so many QTL they're
bursting out of your ears and you so
that's where filtering comes in it's
really important to get the correct
significance of the threshold for
filtering allows us to filter between
the Soniya QTL the good ones and the
thunderous QTL the bad ones and so so
that we process that and take that data
and then so let's have a look at some of
that data
so for our joint linkage results and I'm
not going to bore you with too many
details here but what we have here is
individual locations so north North
Carolina New York Kota Rico and Florida
and then these ones would be a QTL
that's found in multiple locations so
two or more locations and then right at
the bottom here we have I have so this
is a subset of all of the 20/20 that we
were looking at but this is all of them
added together we find that the numbers
that we get for individual locations of
far higher than the numbers we get for
multiple locations and that also plays
into the whole G by E ideas well idea as
well that actually some QTL they don't
explain everything across every location
it's just some things only explain
submit specific things within one
location and let's look at the G was as
well and this is you know you know how I
said he was more liberal so we're
getting thousands here but then look at
two or more locations twenty-nine so
that makes you feel a little deflated
after that right anyway so so that's the
results that we get for the joint
linkage and the G was let's have a look
at them a little bit as well so what we
have now is this is the joint linkage
and G was hits for manganese and
everything is overlapping now so
everything's but we had all these
thousands of QTL but now what we have is
not just thousands but they're all
stacking up upon one in Egypt one in one
another so they actually starting to
make sense a little bit they're telling
us a story and so this is for manganese
and this one's for molybdenum and you
know we were getting so many thousands
of QTL that we were like well what are
we going to do with this how are we
going to sort of tell a story so our the
PIO that we were working with eivin
baxter so his lab actually felt a good
thing strategy to do would be to create
some software so this is zebras that
we're looking at now and it's a browser
that you can use to actually visualize
many of these QTL anyway so the next one
is phosphorus and you see how they're
nicely stacking up nicely there so we
can actually really sort of look down
the region of the chromosome that's of
interest so let's have a look at some of
the genes that are under some of these
stacks so we have just a random
selection here so phosphorous manganese
and molybdenum on chromosomes 9 and at 1
and here once again so we have the
sulfate transporter and then what was I
was telling about earlier the N ramp so
here we found the N ramp so we know this
story already and then we have the MOT 1
so the reason I'm pulling these ones out
for you is because we know these stories
already so I can say to you oh well you
know we've got what we expected but
actually there's a lot we don't know as
well so many of these thousands of QTL
that we got they tell other stories that
maybe we didn't expect at all yeah so
there's more stories to tell but I want
to talk about this one here a little bit
first so Mott 1 now Mara 1 is one of our
favorites because it was originally
found in Arab topsis in the
mitochondrial envelope and that was by
my the PI so you know I got a lucky I
guess
I even Baxter and but also it was
discovered by Josh Cobb as well so in
from the Micucci lab in 2013 and then
the reason that we like it is because
not one is a key regulator of molybdenum
in the genome and it explains about 32
percent seventy percent of the variants
so successful detection of Mar 1 is used
as a quality check for the G was that we
do and because it's so almost a
qualitative gene that we're able to
release if we don't see that gene
showing up in our results then we start
to worry so now that we've looked at the
NAMM we need to think a little bit what
what do we learn from this
so we've looked what adaptations do it
needed to improve analysis so it's
necessary to increase we've learned that
it's necessary to increase statistical
power you know in our association
analyses and then also to increase the
resolution as well
so look familiar so we're back here
again yeah so now let's look at the Mays
diversity panel and that's this big one
in the middle here so we're expecting to
have less power great resolution and
great diversity so we planted these in
Florida Indiana Missouri New York North
Carolina and Puerto Rico and that was
performed we're talking about increasing
our resolution that was performed on
approximately 83 million snips well
before filtration and then we
implemented a multi locus mixed model
and that was in order to reduce false
discovery and increase power as well
okay so we're back to this again and
we're looking at the concentrations at
locations of iron and molybdenum here
are all our locations and then the green
here is where we would expect to see a
good availability of I am but when we
look up here we can clearly see that
we're not getting that in fact it's the
lowest of all of them when we look here
for North Carolina again at 4.5 okay
it's maybe one of the lowest but what
about explain for Florida as well
because that's one of the lowest as well
so clearly something else is going on
here oh sorry so when we look at the
genetic contribution to the phenotypes
that we observe we see that in North
Carolina New York and Indiana for iron
and molybdenum within locations
consistently we're getting higher
results for the genetic contribution but
then when we look across locations we're
finding that it drops suddenly we have
like so so the heritability is easy to
explain within locations but actually
when we look across locations we
actually find that does less it's not as
good as explaining the phenotypes that
we have so we're back to this again so
that we've done that earlier so now
while we're using here we went from
blurps and now we're using residuals
because he was it was a allowing us to
have better normalization of the data
but up the top here so we're going to
talk about this these in a moment at the
top here we implemented a I don't quite
know how to say this because it's kind
of an odd thing to say I'm gonna call it
cage here just because I was advised to
say that so it's basically an adjustment
for population structure and that was
implemented by Alex Lipka who's now
University Illinois whose alumni from
Cornell and so we implemented the MLM
using the cage here population structure
adjustment and then we did that in just
stray
mmm and then also in bootstraps of the
phenotypes we expects the bootstraps to
be more liberal and the do the regular G
was to be more stringent so here we have
QTL again and we're doing liberal and
conservative filtering all those I'm
sorry and we and we did that on the 83
million snips as well okay so let's look
at some of the data so once again what
do we get so this is for the bootstraps
over here then individual locations
through here and then looking just at
the individual locations where the two
or more of those are observed in more
than one - I'm sorry two or more of
those are observed in each of the
individual locations and so for cadmium
phosphorus and zinc we have these
numbers but then looking at the total
numbers across with it for all of the
elements we were getting these really
big numbers again but then we have 19
across all locations so well that that
tells us then that we're getting the
same case again as we did previously in
the Nam but so we wanted to really look
and say well how many did we get in the
Nam and how many did we get in the
diversity panel that different so what
we have here is on the y-axis we have
all of the traits lined up there on the
x-axis we're looking at the numbers of
cutie ELLs and then the red is the
diversity panel numbers of David but
diversity panel QTL and then the blue
ones are common to Nam and the diversity
panel and look how ridiculously small it
is yeah so the point is but that's kind
of what we expected you know we're
looking at different populations we're
looking at different allelic diversity
x' we're looking at in a way that we
kind of should have expected that yeah
and so because we're looking at these
different the broader genetic diversity
we're actually mining a broader set of
lines that we hadn't actually looked at
in the
so in a way this is it's actually
confirms what we'd thought in the first
place so let's look at some of these
genes again under these Peaks that we
were looking at and we have iron cadmium
manganese and molybdenum and then
remember way back in the beginning when
I was talking about yellow striped one
when it goes into the roots here again
we have yellow striped one its
associated with iron but we have these
other ones that may be less you know
expected but cute in biosynthesis
associated with cadmium but we can
explain these away zinc transporter
associated with manganese may be less
expected and then once again our best
friend what one has shown up again so
but look at this no no no three three of
those are actually not found in the NAM
but you know a friend here a qualitative
friend over here is actually found in
the NAMM as well so we're asking we're
finding that actually we're not finding
them in the dough we're not finding them
in them we're actually finding them in
the diversity panel as well so the great
thing with zebras is that it allows us
to really drill deep into the zoom into
the areas where we can actually see the
genes so these are this is a peak of
different snips here QTL and here's a
gene that it possibly is associated
and then also one for manganese and we
have this nice stack just sitting
directly on top of this gene here as
well
okay so I want to move on to the next
population now and this is the last one
so don't panic so we're looking at the
hips and before that I'm going to just
sort of explain briefly how it is that
we created so this probably looks
familiar this is the NAMM recombinant
inbred lines and then from those by
design we have a residual 3% hetero
zygosity point the Cross Lanes
now looking at QTL that we got from the
NEM we were able to then say okay so
we're looking within this QTL we want to
actually find some hetero zygosity
that's actually sits within that locus
and so what we did is that we looked
within a locus and then we're able to
detect heterozygous regions then we
select that one line that takes that
there has that region and then we plant
it out well we sell fit then plant it
out and then then we'll look do GBS
genotyping by sequencing on each of
these lanes and we're able to then to
select homem homozygotes for that region
so here we have two and seven just
random numbers that I picked you that
will actually allow us to find
homozygous opposing alleles so we take
those two and seven up here and then we
can see that they're different at that
low site and then we bulk those out and
then disseminate them to the locations
that we're working at and here are some
of the interesting phenotypes that we
observed in musgraves if anybody's
familiar with my screen so there might
be expected because of the interesting
phenotypes associated with the elements
that we're dealing with
okay so what do we do with these hips
now so we planted them in Florida
Indiana Missouri New York Texas two
locations in simit and Puerto Rico and
the purpose of this we expect that the
hips will reduce the genetic variants
that we see between lanes also we
believe that it will increase the
heritability of the traits that we're
working with and then also the use of we
use that name based QTL for selection of
the hips like it explained already but
then also in order in each of these
locations we have areas of differences
between the lanes so we really wanted to
dig down into a greater resolution
within that so for their reason we you
also used haplotype blocks as well so
this is kind of a zoom in of all of the
lines so this is a subset that you see
here so this is the haplotype blocks
that we're looking at here and each of
these red lines that you see represent a
haplotype block across the genome these
are the chromosomes and then each of
these boxes represents a QTL that we got
from them when we did the UNAM analysis
now the one that we want to look at
right now just as an example for you is
a cadmium QTL that we use to select
lanes and so that's highlighted there in
that section so we really felt that the
the the epitope lock analysis will allow
us to get greater resolution within the
qtls that we're looking at for our
selected lines excuse me so once again
we go through this process of preparing
the phenotype data but working now with
two point two point nine million snips
for the genotype and then now we're
going to run a G was on blocks the
hepatitis and then also G was on the
individual snips as well now we're
getting the QTL and then we're going to
be using the in the intersection of
those QTL in order to find it
QTL of high interest a significant QTL
so this is for cadmium now and on the
Left excuse me on the Left we have a QTL
that is four blocks and then on the
right we have a snip based qtls as well
so so basically we're looking for the
intersection of both of these so here
using zebras once again we're able to
align all of these intersecting QTL we
go from the blocks and the snips and
Yuri have this one very clear peak so
when we zoom in on that peak we find two
sub regions so one is it a hundred and
sixty mega bases and the other is at one
hundred and seventy six mega bases so we
really wanted to know more about the
details of this region so we did a
cholesterol analysis on this and here we
can see that we have three close
clusters so we had a trimodal
distribution of concentrations now for
cluster one over here the green one we
found that we had a mean concentration
of cadmium for those alleles of four
point eighty two milligrams a kilogram
so cluster two that's the black one over
there we had a mean of twenty seven
point seven eight milligrams of kilogram
so there's a difference of 23 milligram
per kilogram there so that's huge
difference so you can see the the box
plots at the bottom here for each of
those clusters so a two and one yeah
so using tests of significance between
these clusters were able to observe that
there is actually a significant
difference between two and one
clusters two and one there there wasn't
a significant difference for cluster
three
so running the G was on individual
locations that was able to tell us that
actually we did all of these locations
at the top but we only found those QTL
in New York so once again that tells us
that so many of our QTL are highly
specific to specific locations my voice
is going ok so so so that really gives
us an idea about the G by E that we're
working with so so what have we learned
we've looked at three populations here
so now we've learnt going back to some
of the original questions that we're
asking what about biofortification and
here we're saying is if we really want
to do biofortification breeding we
really need to understand the G by E and
the application of therefore QTL using
QTL that are applicable to specific
locations so G was helps us to
understand the big picture of
homeostasis we can gain a knowledge of
the complete set of genes we've done
that if we're seeing things that we're
talking about diversity and we get these
QTL that come from that but then also
we're getting location specific QTL
we're getting a lot of them so we
identify QTL for locally for locally
adapted lines and then we're also
getting strong we can get strong
multi-location QTL but maybe we could
have more success with those ones so for
planting across multiple locations in
different regions so for further
investigation so at the end of this what
do we actually get what's the story that
we can tell for the NAMM out of 19 of 20
of the elements we're getting more than
300 low say for each element and the
that's missing there is selenium sorry
Lily
for David the diversity panel we're
getting more than 250 low-side per
element but that's for all elements and
then for the hips
we found the cadmium QTL and a possible
modifier there was upstream at 176 mega
bases so with that I'd like to put
things to arrest and I'd like to thank
my committee members and who are they
you may be wondering so that's Margaret
Smith
Owen ho kanga and Ronnie's over there
and Lily and sincerely really I might
well up now but since silly for
everything that you've done
I really really appreciate oh gosh I am
willing it okay anyway and then I just
want to say thank you for the funding
that I've received as well from the
plant breeding news section and then uh
I've done it feels like a huge amount of
TA I love doing
no luck teeing loves me I think but uh
so Steve - in molecular biology and
genetics and then also working with
Larry smart and Michael Mazurek and then
also research funding from the NSF and
then the top here the our collaborators
Ivan Baxter from and Greg Ziegler the
guy that created zebras I think it's his
last name that's from the Danforth
Center and then also Chad Myers and Rob
Schaffer you know there's another
project that we I haven't actually
talked to you about and that was called
a co-expression browser the Rob Schaffer
was working on his part of his PhD and
what that was a bit so you know you know
how we've actually drilled down to the
gene level and we're kind of interested
we'll what's beyond that you know how
does that fit into a genetic pathway
what's the moleculus of mechanisms
behind that and really as things are
as as we look at them at the moment
we're an unable to do that we can we can
guess but we really want to sort of
drill down even further into
understanding so that's something that
Rob was working on but in the timeline
that I had in order to finish didn't
work out so anyway so we also want to
thank people for germplasm
and plant the planting locations that we
used so in Texas South Murray Natalia
Palacios in and Aldo Rizal is in CIMMYT
Jeff Gaston in Florida Jerry Flynn
Garcia in Missouri
and then here at home Cornell University
sherry Norman Keith Payne and then dan
Fisher on the corner a corn project also
want to thank Deniz academia as time was
running out towards the end it was like
I've got to do this I need some help
so here's Elbert to help me from
statistical consultancy unit but most
but not least where are they oh gosh I'd
like to thank my beautiful wife and my
beautiful daughters they're actually
sitting at the back here today can you
stand up so my wife she's okay anyway I
didn't think I'd be so emotional so with
that I'd like to any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was a huge advantage and then also
thanks to comments yes nitty-gritty but
what are the exact right ear to deciding
whether to yuki-onna the same velocity
location right um yes sorry I always
meant to say that so thank you thanks
you for raising that up so basically
when we were looking at the NAMM the
diversity panel very often we didn't
have snip-snip exactness so so basically
what we did is we created a 2 KB window
either side of the locus that we were
looking at and anything that fell within
that we considered it to be the same
assuming that you know looking at Jason
Wallace's recent paper looking at now
within a 20 KB window upstream and or 10
KB upstream and downstream we felt that
would be a reason to be conservative
right yeah right so at the money to look
at but I mean based on our
multi-location
QTL here at the moment it's big it's all
it is is that the QTL that we can
actually find and detect within one
location in another location if they
exact hits that we can call them the
same thing well that's something we'll
need to look into at some point
you're busting to ask me questions yes I
you sort of just a partition is genetic
and environmental sort of the factor G
Cressy because you also say that nature
nurture phylogeny ontogeny you want to
talk to me later I suppose you could say
that maybe yeah
g'bye yeah nature nurture that might be
a way of putting it yes so the nature
would be you know what's the genetics
and then the nurture would be the
environment that you grown up so
basically that's exactly right that help
thank you okay yes kernels so so
regarding your last question the sample
size so that's not something that was
actually involved in that was something
that Greg was do Greg Ziegler was doing
in the Danville Center
I believe that they took something that
was a happy medium I might be good
actually
we're about out of time but thank you
for coming thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu